inició el juicio contra el que a francia
por montar un sistema de espionaje a sus
empleados el escándalo fue revelado en
2012 por el semanario satírico lo que
hago cine y la web de información
mediapart una investigación que comenzó
tras la denuncia de un sindicato y
sacudió a la filial francesa del gigante
sueco del mueble que los investigaron
sus antecedentes penales sus datos
bancarios fueron muy lejos incluso por
algunas opiniones políticas women por
zack tan de eso que llegará muy lejos
para intentar desacreditar a ciertos
empleados a ciertos sindicalistas pues
siguiendo en diferentes zonas alcanzar
alianzas ante la investigación ha
revelado según la fiscalía un sistema de
espionaje de los empleados pero también
de los candidatos a acceder a un empleo
y se produjo por todo el país
la empresa habría utilizado detectives y
policías contra más de 70 trabajadores
este lunes además de la empresa como
persona jurídica comparecieron también
15 personas entre las que se encuentran
gerentes de tiendas agentes de policía
pero también
ejecutivos pero para la defensa la
investigación contiene muchos puntos
débiles
le recuerdo que no existe estrictamente
ninguna calificación penal relativa a un
sistema de espionaje basta con leer los
términos del requerimiento de reenvío
para convencerse de ello y por lo que
decir que había un sistema generalizado
de espionaje en esta empresa es
materialmente y jurídicamente falso los
acusados comparecen por hechos que
abarcan el periodo 2009-2012 aunque
estas prácticas se remontan a principios
de la década de 2000 según la parte
denunciante en el juicio que durará
hasta el 2 de abril los acusados tendrán
que defenderse de recopilación y
divulgación ilegal de información
personal violación del secreto
profesional y ocultación lo que podría
suponer para algunos de ellos una
condena de hasta 10 años de prisión